not many products on the German market
get past the shifting vahrin test
controllers employees the country's
independent consumer testing board hand
out grades like a school teacher would
the organization is renowned for its
rigor hardly any other German
organization enjoy such widespread
support eighty percent of Germans say
they trust the stiff dong Lauren test
many consumers consult its findings
before making a purchase a few inquiries
are definitely a good thing I think it's
a valuable thing to have its
ninety-eight percent reliable West
Germany in the early 1960s with years of
economic growth behind them consumers
now faced a huge choice for some it was
overwhelming the government led by
konrad adenauer responded by setting up
an independent national consumer board
the shift on boren test it started its
work 50 years ago first up for testing
hand mixers consumers wanted to know
which brand performed best on safety and
efficiency satisfy the reason 50 we see
again that these kinds of whisks have a
significant advantage over there hooked
equivalent in this one the dough never
rises up whereas here it comes up easily
like the daylight the organization's
results were published and distributed
widely the testing procedures are known
for being quite innovative these
children were testing the quality of a
pair of tights
while this model produced sweat like an
athlete as an independent organization
its criteria are often stricter than
those required by law strict guidelines
are generally good news for consumers
but for manufacturers a bad grade can be
hugely damaging and in the past there
has been controversy and scientists
crucial that the consumer group adheres
to legal requirements and frameworks
when that's not the case the potential
damage could amount to millions shooting
on Steam take chocolate maker with our
sport it was accused of mislabeling the
flavorings in its nut chocolate bar and
was graded mongol hoft or pour it
contested the findings and the grade was
later retracted apart from that blip the
organization's reputation has remained
largely unsullied and most German
consumers give it 10 out of 10